[Music]
[Applause]
19:07 aboat chugs
into New York Harbor one passenger
seventeen-year-old Ida Moss clamors to
the front of the ship appears over the
shoulders of the crowds that have
gathered trying to catch a glimpse of
land Ida had fled home in the middle of
the night weeks before as violence had
spread across the Lithuanian countryside
she traveled alone she didn't speak a
word of English and all of her
belongings fit in one ragged suitcase as
she tried to peer out all of a sudden
the clouds parted and the ultimate
beacon of hope Lady Liberty's torch
gleamed in the sunshine
I love imagining Ida's journey to New
York this way because I don't actually
know a lot about her life but if not for
this journey I wouldn't be here today
because Ida was my great-grandmother I
this journey represents an important
part of my personal historical timeline
I thought a lot about my personal
history because some years ago I was a
history teacher and I had to justify to
my students why they should learn
history to make better future trust me
this was not always easy but one of the
things I've learned is that there are
some people who are especially good at
this and these people I call historian
leaders what is the historian leader the
Astoria leader learns lessons from the
past to build a better future they lived
their lives in historical context one of
the things that the historian leader can
do to do this easily is think about
timelines so share for a moment my
personal timeline remember Ida 110 years
ago she travelled the United States from
Lithuania for three generations this
story has inspired my family has taught
us to live our lives with courage and to
work hard to pass on a better life to
our descendants
her story also embodies an important
belief of mine that the violence that
caused her to flee her home was
something that should never be repeated
and that we would only be able to do
that if we've learned the lessons from
history so that's my timeline an
important lesson from the past pointing
to the future now it's a timeline it's
helpful to know where we are today and
where we're going tomorrow but there's a
risk that we take too short of a view
maybe you've had an experience like this
with the GSB I've been tempted to
dismiss a case because it's 20 years old
but the reality is it's the long view of
history that helps us learn those
enduring lessons that stand the test of
time
because it's not necessarily the
specific technology or leader that's
most important or looking forward I
spend a lot of my time these days
seeking career advice or trying to
predict the next disruptive technology
I'm really curious about what can happen
tomorrow or next quarter or the next
four years but I worry that if I don't
think longer out I may miss the
important lessons that show me what I
was meant to do here on this planet with
my one life this is what the historian
leader does all the time they are
concerned with the change that their
concern with change over time but their
view is over generations the historian
leader is not so concerned necessarily
with the fate of an individual product
or company but with the state of
civilizations what would the world look
like if we had more historian leaders I
think it might be helpful if I would
share with you the story of the first
historian leader who got me excited
about history when I was 16 I was like
most middle-class American kids I was
pretty self-absorbed I like TV and
sports and I had a vision of my future
mansion that I would hopefully one day
buy but when I read Howard Zinn in my US
history class it completely changed my
perspective
Howard Zinn was a world war two vet
turned history professor turned
influential activists who have involved
in the civil rights movement the
anti-vietnam war movement and the labor
movement was when he was doing his
master's research that he discovered an
historical event was a major inspiration
for him in 1914 there had been a coal
mine strike in Colorado the US National
Guard was called in and ended up being
responsible for the deaths of a number
strikers their wives and their children
for Zinn this was a moment of injustice
in American history that continued to
repeat itself and he continually came
back to this when he chose to involve
himself in labor strikes to step out and
speak up in the anti-vietnam war
movement and this in the civil rights
movement now Howard Zinn as a historian
leader didn't just learn from the past
to try to build a better future but he
also was exemplary in thinking about
scope so in his book he traces American
history from the arrival of Columbus
through to today and his vision of the
future was of old world without violence
imagine that as in didn't think this
would happen tomorrow he knew it would
take generations and he didn't expect it
would happen in his lifetime but it was
the boldness of this vision that
inspired millions of his readers and
followers to work towards that audacious
goal the historian leader isn't just a
historian leader it can come in many
forms another favorite of mine is Elon
Musk whose transportation company is
named after a 19th century investor
inventor excuse me Elon Musk's vision of
the future is radically different from
today when he talks about missions to
Mars if it is achieved
it may not be him driving it but
somebody in the next generation who is
inspired by him imagine a world with
more historian leaders what if we all
were historian leaders I like to
give you guys one idea that you can take
away from today if you choose to walk
the path of the historian leaders take
out your hands and hold them like this
in this hand I'd like you to imagine the
important historical influences in your
life it could be your parents your
grandparents maybe it includes some key
historical figures that inspire you
imagine that maybe introduce them to
each other in your other hand I want you
to imagine the future
these could be your children or
grandchildren it could be people that
you have mentored or will mentor it
could be the people that you hope will
lead our country and institutions in the
future in your two hands in you you
always have both the past and the future
this is your timeline complete hands
down the historian leader learns from
the past to make a better future to be a
historian later use the timeline as a
tool to remember where you came from to
remember where you're going and to go go
there boldly and I will see you in the
history books thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh